foreign
George joins us up next in Columbus Ohio
George welcome to the show
hey George hey John thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's going on
so I'm 29 years old recently engaged to
love my life she's awesome
um
and I have a question about our kind of
situation so we both went through
Financial Peace University together a
couple months ago obviously doing it
together but keeping our finances
separate until we get married
um I'm in baby steps four and six she's
in baby step two so my question is
obviously we've been through Financial
Peace University but what can I do and
we do together whether it's from the
financial side or the relational side to
put ourselves in the best position
possible when getting married in July
how much does she owe
so she owes about 220 000 yeah y'all
should break up man I'm totally playing
don't do that George don't do that don't
do it
what is uh what's she do is she working
or is she still in school
so sort of in school so she's in her
residency for medical school
so she uh all her debt is the medical
school uh student loans so she's uh
going into year two starting here in a
couple weeks so okay so what will
y'all's income be when you get married
we're getting married our income
together would be roughly
170. and then it would go way up after
she's done with residency
correct yeah okay are you able to cash
flow the rest of this you have two years
left after this or three years left
or she going to some sort of specialty
right so the the debt itself is done so
she's uh she's actively working here
residency this is a schooling done okay
she's she's making an income now with
the with the wrestling team yeah it
usually just depends on the type of
residency how much longer does she have
after this she's in year two how far is
she gonna go
uh just two more years so two years
starting in July so she'll be done in
the summer of 2025. okay cool so you're
you're right on the path you're doing
all the right things keep the finances
separate she's running her own race
right now until you guys are married and
up until then what you can do is stack
up as much cash as you can obviously be
sure to cash flow all the wedding
expenses and once you're back from the
honeymoon we're gonna make that joint
account we're gonna lay it all out and
go how much debt do we have left how
much do I have in savings above the
emergency fund or even taking that down
to a thousand for a little while and how
can we clean this up fast and making 170
she has 220 in debt is that all of her
debt
correct yeah it's just the medical
school debt okay so looking at this I'm
like cool can we live off 60 and throw
110 at the debt and be done with this in
two years
and boom all of a sudden we're debt free
and now the income is Spike because
she's done with residency and now we're
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
completely debt free
pretty soon into our marriage and here's
the cool part
um
I know they've they've actually dialed
back a lot of the hours on The Residency
um what's what's our hour load now
what's like an average week for her
it's uh it's on a rotational basis so an
eight-week chunk streets goes to
different rotations sometimes it's 40
sometimes it's up to 80. yeah it just
kind of depends on competition I knew it
used to be the days of the
the 120 hours you sleep four days four
hours a week those are over but
here's the deal what George just said is
so right and if y'all look at your
relationship over the next two years
I can't think of a better time for you
all to constrict your discretionary
spending
because she's going to be working a lot
and you're going to be working a lot and
her head is going to be learning like
she's never learned before trying to
make sure people aren't Dead all that
stuff you're going to be learning how to
be married she is too young but this is
a perfect moment for you all to really
collapse your
big budget stuff and just budget for
food take your lunches make breakfast
together in the morning have dinner at
home when she's able to get home and
really constrict your day-to-day
spending
can you just imagine for a second she
walks across that stage at graduation
she is done she is a licensed medical
doctor and you all owe nobody anything
you realize you have won at that point
the cosmic Lottery
it's over that'd be amazing
yeah it's it's something we're
definitely looking forward to and day by
day taking you step by step there you go
man here we have for sure here's an
important thing and Dave's has taught me
this privately just us sitting like it's
just a blessing that I get to sit by him
and and and dig into his wisdom
um keep their ratios in mind how much
money do you make by yourself at your
job
uh my current job I make 100 000 and
then I have a side hustle where I make
about 5 000 a year okay so you make a
hundred grand and you're you're a hard
worker you're you got two jobs going so
you make 105.
220 000 sounds like a billion dollars
and it feels out of control and somewhat
insane
if you just extrapolate out the fact
that you're marrying a medical doctor
who's going to make um salary X Y or Z
down the road the ratio of this debt
becomes a little bit more manageable and
in simpler terms you got a big hole but
you're going to have a huge shovel
to fill it back up with does that make
sense so keep those ratios in mind and
again George said it right man you don't
get a plan together and just don't
deviate from the plan stay on the plan
stay on the plan stay on the plan y'all
going to look up in two years don't buy
new cars don't buy fancy Apartments
you're gonna look up at two years and
owe nobody anything your wife's gonna
smile with that big MD and you're gonna
smile and it's gonna be game on I'm
pumped for this George you're on the
path man you excited
absolutely yeah it's something going
through financial peace we got fired up
and now it's just you know I kind of
expected what you guys are going to say
to some degree but hearing it and
validating let me let me say this you
know what I want more than anything
I want an entire
swath of medical doctors to not have any
student loan debt you know why because
then they can practice medicine exactly
as their heart leads them
and they can practice medicine that is
evidence-based and not
um
not hospital administrator based
they can look at individual patients and
make individualized decisions because if
somebody gets mad that they quote
unquote stepped out of line who cares I
don't owe anybody anything
when you have a group of professionals
that are in that powerful of a position
that don't owe anybody nothing
then they can lead with their expertise
and their heart and now you've got as
Peter attia says you got medicine 3.0 at
that point they can stop you know what
I'm not going to prescribe your
medication you need to start exercising
and then when they get enough complaints
they can say okay I'm just going to go
to a hospital that uh fill in the blank
right so man good for you this is the
kind of your wife's the kind of Doctor
Who is going to change the Health Care
system for my kids so good for you guys
man I'm I'm grateful that y'all as a
couple exist in the world man when's the
wedding you got a date
wedding is July 6 2024. oh you got some
time move it up what are you doing what
are we doing man
love of your life she's gonna meet some
smoke show at some resident dude I'm
telling you move it up
uh I'll try I'll talk to her tonight yes
Justice of the piece this weekend in the
meantime making a hundred grand for the
next year how much money could you save
up so that when you guys get married and
you have that joint bank account you go
honey I got 70 grand sitting here ready
to start knocking out this debt she's
gonna give you a big old smooch I'll
tell you that much right now gross